malgré le recul en fin de journée sur
les marchés l'indicé s p500 quand même
établi un record en cours de séance pour
une deuxième journée de suite le nasdaq
ça fait trois jours consécutifs où on
établi des records et puis à paul dont
la valeur explose dépasse maintenant on
le disait les 2000 milliards de dollars
c'est comme si la crise n'existait pas
on en discute avec simon plantes
il est gestionnaire de portefeuille
premier vice-président la financière
banque nationale merci d'être là
monsieur plante alors un titre qui a
doublé depuis le creux du mois de mars
2000 milliards aujourd'hui que l'on
explique ça mais au mois de mars on se
rappelle la société avait complètement
lui ses projections de ventes on était
dans l'inconnu puis au 30 juillet
dernier la société publie ses résultats
l'ont eu des bonnes nouvelles croissance
des ventes dans tous les secteurs
d'activité quand je parle croissance des
ventes c'est autour des 10 pour ça les
ventes en chine aussi ont surpris puis
actuellement senti un engouement il ya
des remarques iphone iphone 12 soit
compatible avec les réseaux singer donc
tous a rendu les investisseurs
enthousiasme à propos de l'enthousiasmé
c'est boulot mais est-ce que c'est
justifié est-ce que c'est réaliste ou
c'est complètement exagéré et c'est sur
évalué à pau aujourd'hui je n'aurais pas
complètement exagéré mais le trille et
chats sont garde sans vous l'avez
mentionné leur en 2018 il ya deux ans la
société se transigent à 15 fois des
profits aujourd'hui à environ 30 fois
les profils dont d'argent pour le même
dollars de profits les élections qui
sont prêts à payer deux fois plus cher
donc c'est vraiment grimper faut pas
oublier que quand même des enjeux 40%
des ventes de à pau c'est la réforme
puis 80% des composantes ont fabriqué en
chine peut avoir un enjeu de ce côté là
et puis tout récemment en haut vues le
fabricant de jeux forte mais il est des
anges avec la pop star
on dit qu'ils ont manque de concurrence
et monopolistiques
donc ça reste que quand conjugue
l'évaluation plaisant jeu que sur la
table ou personnages trouvent
l'évaluation 26 manches à l'autre
question qu'on se pose c'est
certainement été rap et de cette montée
est ce que ça va se poursuivre on vous
laissait entendre que des risques quand
même il ya des années est aujourd'hui
qu'ils s'amusaient à parier à quel
moment on va atteindre les 3000 mai
ja vous prévoyez vous que ça va grimper
encore on ne sait pas du tout si un
momentum donc sa puce poursuivre qui ça
reste que l'entreprise est qualité à un
avantage compétitif bonne équipe de
direction c'est jusqu'à personnages
trouvent l'évaluation est relativement
élevé mais aussi on fait face à une
autre réalité
ça touche tout l'étude pas seulement le
titre d'abord qu'on ait investi on
regarde c'est quoi l'alternative
finalement déplacements sécuritaires les
taux d'intérêt ont tellement baissé à
aujourd'hui on tant aux états unis qu'au
canada sont vos investissements émis par
l'auteur de 10 ans d'échéance les taux
sont en baisse de 0 4% donc plus en plus
de gens qui décident d'investir dans les
marchés boursiers dont dans un rapport
qui vient positionner
parce qu'on se dit bien et probablement
on va faire de meilleurs rendements
donc tant qu'ils aient tout m'intéresse
vraiment beau niveau qu'on qu'on est ici
c'est pas surprenant de voir des
évaluations élevé dans le marché ouais
vous ben justement quand un terrain on
est un petit investisseur qu'on regarde
ça allait on se dit est ce que j'ai
manqué le bateau est ce que j'achète
maintenant si j'ai des petits traits ce
que je lis venge en poche un bon profit
qu'est ce qu'on fait avec ça
la seconde question personnelle ma
stratégie pour la nouvelle liquidités
j'achète sur faiblesse on est bon on ne
répond pas vraiment surprenant faut pas
oublier son prend pas de recul une année
sur toi la bourse offre un rendement
négatif donc des reculs il va en avance
avec la maman pour investir par contre
la réalité pour ceux qui voudraient
acheter les titres technologie au canada
de chaque fois et on a appo google
microsoft ces sociétés bénéficient
tellement de ce qui se passe avec le co
vide que je doute qu'ils reculent d'un
niveau vraiment drastique si quelqu'un
cherche ces aubaines est obligée
aujourd'hui c'est d'aller à la pêche
dans des secteurs qui ont été délaissés
parce que là la remontée à pau était
égale entre les secteurs oui
effectivement mais justement dans
l'ensemble les indices boursiers je
parlais d'un record encore au cours de
la séance pour le s&p 500 même chose
pour le nasdaq on a l'impression que sur
les marchés la crise économique la
pandémie ça n'existe pas comment on
explique sa mère assise sur les gens
regardent ce qui se passe dans
l'économie puis 10 avril exactement
projeté en bosses ça c'est faux il ya
d'autres facteurs
face aux gens mentionné le si les taux
d'intérêt donc ils disent aujourd'hui on
est un fonds de pension qui ondoie
général
24% pour les retraités des bénéficiaires
notre compassion on regarde le marché
des titres à revenu fixe les taux sont
négatifs en asie en europe sont prêts à
bord canada et aux états unis
ce que ça fait les investisseurs vont
opter pour pour la bourse que cette
cadence la vaste rester va rester comme
je mentionnais aussi et des sociétés de
technologie qui avait vraiment des plans
d'affaires très compétitif pour les
prochaines années
amazon par exemple mais avec le co vide
s'est amplifiée donc aujourd'hui si on
regarde la bourse de new york on a
l'impression que tout le monde il faut
pas oublier que les cinq six grandes
sociétés et ici en bourse à new york
représente 25% lundi situation piste
c'est la raison pour laquelle il ya
certaines personnes qui se demandent est
ce qu'on est en train de vivre une autre
bulle ou si une deuxième vague est ce
qu'on va voir un autre décrochage en
règle quand même beaucoup d'inquiétude
la lecture personnelle du marché on
n'est pas dans un environnement 2 comme
on inverse 999 hollande
si des sociétés à l'époque qui était la
rentabilité est vraiment différente
aujourd'hui on a deux sociétés qui se
transige à des multiples de 30 fois les
profits c'est dispendieux
par contre on n'est pas dans un niveau
niveau 2 pour ce qui est de l'impact
d'une deuxième vague des auteurs qu'on
peut être avons été surpris de la chute
drastique du rebond si la réalité du
marché on peut pas prévoir les
mouvements donc pour un investisseur je
pensais vraiment prudent de regarder
l'évolution du marché au quotidien de
quelques faiblesses et d'acheter des
sociétés de qualité - c'est ça dans quel
type d'industrie vous pensé au tourisme
et au commerce de détail ce genre de
choses mais que le secteur du commerce
du commerce en ligne est vraiment
prometteur
les versions actuelles c'est quand même
10 pendule donc je prendrai pas position
complète par contre les secteurs
d'activité qui ont peu bougé entendu
parler du secteur du tourisme
je crois que dans quelques années
lorsqu'on va pouvoir voyager on voit les
habitudes de consommation de les gens
quand même trop chaud mais ils vont re
migrer vers le tourisme secteur à
surveiller
on parle de l'hôtellerie même les
espaces à bureaux commerciaux je pense
le secteur va être bouleversée mais il
ya certaines sociétés qui peuvent mieux
tiré leur épingle du jeu que d'autres
on attend vos conseils merci beaucoup
monsieur plante un jours merci